okay it's a here spoiler corner give me
that
okay so first they would you say it off
the bat it's con I think everybody knew
that going in
but yeah I will say okay let me say this
most of the spoilers up until the end I
thought were good although I had figured
them out all about five minutes ahead of
time before they reveal them cuz I think
you were gonna smack me cuz I kept with
me
I think that's Carol Marcus shut up yeah
so I mean there's a lot of familiar
characters that come back here you know
and the big one is that it's Cod a lot
of people probably guess that so but the
guy does great and the I didn't have any
problem with that yeah is that you
actually made a perfect hunt now here's
the thing I will say this he is space
seed Cod which was different from the
super human con yet well and British Cod
apparently he's British yeah I know
they're obviously they're just gonna
they he does not even attempt a Cuban
accent you know that's his own thing
yeah this is not fantasy character yeah
and this is the thing I mean don't go
into this expecting you know people who
complain about him being conned remember
this this is not Wrath of Khan Khan he
altered Ricardo Montalban altered his
performance a bit it definitely had a
sort of different vibe to it this is
more of a space seed con of super
intellectual just revised every human
yeah basically the super human and he
this God he sells it a Benedict
Cumberbatch completely sells it um I
thought he was legitimately terrifying
he was legitimately threatening there's
a scene where he goes on and the his
love for his crew which they ripped from
you know Wrath of Khan does calm this
concept that you know is constant you
know one side was a bit tough man you
know so you have this concept that he
really is attached to his crew and that
was the last thing a wrap of Khan you
know when his version of Starbuck dies
now I would have n Julia you know so
that was a very integrates and
interesting dynamic between him and Kirk
which is they both love their crew and
it's you know what do you do you know
the Spock's solution to that as well
with the torpedoes was brilliant the one
the best things that I wish they did
more of I thought maybe this was the
direction they were gonna go into before
we get to the ending
is that him and Kirk are very similar
and actually have to join forces and are
sort of working off each other for a bit
and I almost will found it interesting
if they created this reality where
they're almost friends and they're
almost going that route but they're also
sort of keeping an eye I JA and that
stuff was great and I wish it went
longer but I like the fact that they put
them together together
that was brilliant the the Alliance of
convenience and I'm a huge fan of
alliances of conveniences and
screenplays and stuff it's always an
interesting dynamic so it's definitely
an alliance of convenience in the middle
that's where didn't bother me I saw
Carol Marcus coming a mile away the
second is like oh yeah I'm Carol Wallace
Admiral Marcus sent me I'm like I wonder
who this is she even looks kind of like
BB Bash from you know Star Trek too like
I just forgot about that character to
remind me I'm like oh okay yeah she had
is the blonde is like I could kind of
see this this would be a really really
young version you know the one we saw
from Wrath of Khan um that does well too
it's not well to every case although
they do exploit it there is a fanservice
moment but I promised Lee it's lame it
did not bother me too much because it
could have been so much worse yes I made
it quick but it's still stupid um
somebody was complaining that there's
like oh no they did nothing with her
character there was I never felt that
she and Kirk were in love I was like I
think you missed the point this was the
character's introduction yeah this is
the begin which is why is a fanservice
moment didn't bother me because I think
Kirk was kind of getting that whole like
oh she's kind of attractive you know and
I think he was kind of scoping her out
like I think it is the purpose of the
fanservice scene - honestly I think
that's the purpose of it they just push
a little too far she frame it she has
liked it afterward I mean Kirk comes off
as a creeper basically like you know
he's kind of was yeah it's like that's
five all you need is him turning in her
saying turn around oh you don't need to
show everything that was the fanservice
in my yeah she looks great buzz oh and
Mike I was worried that they were gonna
make her character just a blonde bimbo
and when I was all said and done like no
she's kind of like a gwen stacy she's
brilliant the her whole story arc with
her father always a lot yes fascinating
now here's the thing she gets kicked in
the stomach by Khan which I thought was
the leg I thought she could wasn't the
lake
somewhere I know she's hit by cohn yeah
well you think she'd break in half or
something with it no I was wondering if
this is something like I was like was
she pregnant or something were they like
I don't know it just seemed very weird
for me because I grabbed her somebody's
just setting up something later because
she has Kirk's son and Star Trek well in
between the tracks but you know it we
haven't seen son is in Star Trek - yes I
didn't know if there was some weird for
sharing or some plot when you're trying
to keep open I don't know but people
don't want to hear is Dogma if you've
seen this you probably said oh you know
what you want us to talk about okay so
let's discuss the ending here yes turn
okay to do to even attempt to do what
they want to do which is to replay the
ending to Star Trek - only with the
roles reversed with Kirk and Spock is
not the most arrogant task on the planet
it is the most ambitious task I'm not
going to claim it's hubris or arrogance
I'm going to claim it's over ambition
and it is like scaling Mount Everest you
have to know exactly what you're doing
you have to have trained for this revver
and if you don't have a clear plan to
know exactly what you're doing going
into trying to attempt this you're gonna
botch it and that is what happened these
are clever screenwriters who I think
have scaled some pretty good mountains
in their day and just suddenly decided
you know what let's do it we're gonna do
Mount Everest now and they got close to
the top and slip and fell off a cliff
and was there so yeah I mean that is
what happened it is an idea that can
work it's not impossible but it is so
difficult
I disagree I don't know I don't think it
can work um well I put this way I do not
see a way it can work but pretty much
what happens if you probably know but if
you don't at the end Kirk sacrifices his
life like save the crew just like Spock
did in Star Trek - isn't that kind of
similar almost word-for-word
Scotty call Spock down who's now
captain's down it's through the window
it's literally wild-eyed he's dead
already
some lines are changed but so many are
recited verbatim that it that was my
biggest from it was so distracting to
hear those same lines again I'm like no
ship out of danger yeah
uh Kirk you know puts his hand up spot
does the thing they do the little thing
they talk through the window
Kirk dies even though they make it
unbelievably clear about 30 minutes
earlier how he's gonna be brought back
hey bones why you messing with that
Tribble I'm like come on I'm like this
is screenwriting 101 trying to see if
Kassadin luck will bring him back to
life you know I mean I was like saying
the fact that it hinges on a Tribble I'm
like okay I know you want to do a fan
give me that back I know you went to a
fan service a moment but seriously when
you're just like yeah we're gonna have
it be a Tribble I'm like oh I mean it
this is literally you see it's almost
they change the lines around but
obviously you cannot connect emotionally
to this at all because all you are
thinking is how somewhere this is to
start right and that was my but then how
it's intentional obviously and just as
this is why I'm saying that it can work
it's just really hard you have to not
copy it word-for-word had you come up
with a more original way to do this or
to put it or put a twist on it but to do
it exactly the same way it's like Gus
Van Sant's remake of psycho you're just
distracting because you're just thinking
wow how much better Star Trek to the
Wrath of Khan was oh that's all I was
thinking was like I'm like I should be
feeling some emotion here but all I'm
thinking is how much this was done
better by Nicholas my hair and how about
what after you know Kirk dies the exact
same way you know yeah luck is not the
one who goes God like that I mean we
were you my honey are you fucking ki I
laughed and I laughed hard we may have a
moment that finally after so many years
finally beats Darth Vader going Macchio
and Khan is so ridiculous it is so
stupid it's stupid scene and it's stupid
on paper it is a horrible ending and
then on top of that this isn't as bad
but it's still bad in my opinion spot
goes after the superhuman cuz now it was
asked what is the most lame climax it
basically it's like me it's like a
fugitive no the Balkan no no not even
the fugitive it's batman begins with the
whole monorail chase at the end if they
just recycled the monorail chase it's
Spock and Khan battling on a monorail
and I'm like really
so you crashed the super awesome stealth
starship which was great you crashed
that that was an awesome set piece Khan
wants to crash it into Starfleet
headquarters which is right out of Wrath
of Khan for me in a good way like that's
like his Genesis attack like I'm gonna
take you fuckers all out he crashes the
ship straight into San Fran said I'm
like amazing
I was like now how you gonna top this
cuz that was out as I can fight an honor
our BioShock Infinite has a more
fascinating like flying railcar sequence
and that's a video game like and here's
the thing - okay so you are building up
calm wonderfully you're building up this
in this great character you know it's
Ricker and and you're building at you
know who he is and they even say there's
a pointless cameo by Larry Nimoy who
says you know Khan was one of the most
dangerous people we've ever come across
they are building this fucker up and as
much as like cameo is completely
pointless as much as it was I love that
first look and learn
Nimoy sways have you ever met a person
named Khan and Leonard Nimoy just Spock
who's normally emotionless
ah crap um and so you're building this
guy up his people he thinks are now
destroyed and Spock destroyed them you
know and I mean he is destroyed now his
world is gone and you think what's the
feeling is this gonna bill up for
another movie which I would accept
because there's so much going on in this
movie you build a of Exile on to sette
up for six in this universe lady comes
back oh he could you've had him re-enter
turn of the rehash of Khan could you
hadn't gotten away and you know vows
vengeance I can't spot cuz we get it
there's a lot of movie here and this is
such a huge character you got given to
movies we got it know they resort to a
not very impressive fight on top of some
cars after a miserable crash I say baby
boring my sense because Spock is now
super-strong he's got a Vulcan I know I
know Vulcans when they you know get all
horny or whatever can you know fight to
the death pretty impressive way I saw
the really I did not know that
oh yeah no Kirk and Spock have a fight
and like Vulcans can be pretty strong
but like I'm not buying that Khan the
Superman is really gonna go down this
easily well here
the thing Spock handles himself really
well and yet at the same time who
ravines down and fires with a stun face
yeah okay first one and it didn't work
for Scotty scared no Scotty hits him
once and he goes don't sound like a
bitch and then where I hit some eight
times and I can take it no I can take it
out I can take it wait
Sparky some house holding his own is
Spock the Man of Steel now like I don't
yet he knocked him out even though Kirk
hit him about a dozen times I had no
effect on him obviously yet somehow
Spock Vulcan Nick bit the Vulcan neck
pinch works on him didn't get that these
are the time took a little extra effort
oh yeah I mean on and if this is what
kills me is it was such a clever
screenplay up until that point and it
got so ridiculous and on top of that
amateur before the epilogue is very
rushed and for all this buildup of this
con character and don't get done so well
they just throw him back in the freezer
Kirk goes oh well and space the final
frontier
that it is a gettable ending yeah the
last in pretty much from the point that
Scotty says Spock you'd better get down
here you know travel from that point in
the movie on it blows it and it blows at
big time it is one moment where it it
comes back and that's when Khan crashes
the ship into San Francisco I thought
maybe we'll have some Redemption and
then it ends with the lay monorail
chains it's such a waste of talent and
it's such bush leagues like
screenwriters tell like I don't maybe
someone else was hired and maybe I
shouldn't be I really feel like maybe
they'll be the green riders are gonna
come out at some point be like that
wasn't me no though total rewrite at
some point and that's not what we had at
all but it's kind of unfathomable it's
like cuz it was young so well on its own
and it wasn't that needed no the issue
is it is not impossible to do the
concept of a role reversal is a good one
but you have to put a twist there was a
hint of a twist and I thought if they go
this route they may be able to salvage
this which is the concept that Spock had
already felt Chris Pine Christopher
yeah Chris Pine pike died he had felt
Pike died and Kirk was not there when
Pike and Kirk comes in later so there's
this weird sort of dynamic of like Spock
now knows what it feels like to die and
he tells something wherever anot on
interest
yeah and and and Kirk you know I think
somehow feels almost like in a way that
he missed out because he wasn't there
for Pike says so there's this dynamic of
like Kirk is legitimately afraid I'm
like well here's something interesting
you don't see that much because God
knows when Shatner would never allow it
but you know Kirk is vulnerable and
afraid Spock is defenseless to do
anything has to relive this now kind of
a second time I'm like yeah you follow
the way to do something interesting with
that consciously like I'm ripping off
Joe yeah Leo has no concept that it
brings out Spock's human side his human
emotion of pure rage that's all really
good and yet they got so bogged down and
let's repeat this word-for-word line
from line them whatever goodwill you
were earning trying to put that original
spin on it you just did you're
distracted you're far yeah that's right
which is why I think it could be done
but you have to ditch that we're
remaking the scene no you have to put an
original spunk a so you're talking about
not having them in the glad so you're
talking about like it's somewhere else
like somewhere else on the ship around a
mountain or something like yeah if you
want it still has it or diet you wanted
to do it in the glass you would have to
have completely ditched the same lines
come up with a more original spin remove
Spock shouting kaneen you basically have
to tread with with such skill to say yes
we're kind of doing this same scene it's
a similar scenario this is a different
twist on it there was no different twist
there was a hint of a different twist
none of its same lines repeated it was
really really lame and the funny thing
is like we're I was talking about the
best scene there is Simon Pegg and Zoey
yeah when it is no lines I shut up when
it cuts back when it cuts back to -
Scottie and Ahura I choked up and they
have no lines they have like six seconds
of screen time to evoke everything
through the emotion in their face and
I'm like there that's where somebody got
it and like I'm wondering maybe the
scene would have actually worked had
there
very little if any dialogue I'm like
maybe they just needed to step back and
say screw dialogue what if he just has
to watch what if Kirk is only barely
aware that Spock is even out there
doesn't even know what if Kirk is just
dying and having a few gotten Spock
can't do anything else watchable yes yes
what I would have rewritten like that
where Spock has to watch somebody his
you know quote unquote now best friend
die is trapped on the outside of glass
can't do anything because that was the
secret of the Star Trek 2 scene is the
fact that Kirk always thought he had it
under control and for the first time
ever he's helpless he's on the other
side of glass he's trapped and Nikolas
Meyers got that he shoots Kirk's
reaction more like and you get that
feeling and to Cheddar's credit he
accent beautifully um no sorry no it
actually has a pretty no and the way he
slumps and sinks there's this you feel
like Kirk's been killed as well and like
they just didn't get that there's just
no fricking emotion to that scene I'm
like come on this should be like the
centerpiece oh you know I don't even in
the original movies
Spock comes back they have a whole movie
bringing him back realizing his memory
than a movie after that we're a long way
back no no and what is it you got the
triple and they just wakes up that
hustle but oh I am okay thanks but I
guess I'm all right nothing of what
wrong carpet thanks for reviving me yeah
well this is even boses like I'll come
on it was easy again it's like biology I
give it like Elizabeth just takes it
short syringe like and you wake up okay
now I get to play you know the next game
it it a lot of disappointment what you
which disappoint to an otherwise it's
one day on Star Trek and I can't and I
can't fathom it because and that's why I
hate eggs because I said earlier it's
like kicking a puppy because it's like
or it's like it's like beating up on
your own child like for a mistake they
may because they you know they duck well
no no no I mean dark
what are we beating up but like you know
it's like something you love suddenly
being like you're not good enough yeah
no okay let me put its way it's like
raising your kid to do the right thing
and throughout all of their life they
did and then all of a sudden they kill
somebody and you're just like what
happened
and it's just like and you're just like
you go through all these immersion right
here I'm connection to Star Trek and
child murder
no nutshell well another child it has
murdered I'm just trying to make you
some worse okay I'm just saying it's
like I loved this so much and then to
watch you just kind of like stab you in
the back like that like oh so those are
the major spoilers of the film and just
the toughest stuff to get another why is
a really great Star Trek film I just how
do you do I don't know but the rest is
so smart I mean we're we're just gonna
keep repeating ourselves now but yeah
hopefully uh you know maybe you agree
maybe you don't maybe you liked it I
have known to shoot some Klingons that's
true oh yeah those like that Lance do so
and Carol Marcus is hot so there you go
take care guys of mine I hated it worse